[Music]
right for more on what we call selective
moral outrage on this program we bring
in Juanita Broderick remember she told
the story about Bill Clinton and rape
back in the 70s also with us the author
of the number one New York Times
bestseller the Russia hoax Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarek Juanita I I did
the second interview with you and even
through this last election a lot of the
people we're hearing from now they were
silent yeah they never wanted it didn't
want an FBI investigation for you that I
remember
oh no I senator Feinstein and Senator
Durbin and Senator Schumer wanted
nothing to do with my case all Democrats
refused to read my deposition with the
Independent Counsel wouldn't they never
once reached out to you know people that
are still there the ones acting you know
so they're the ones that are so
supportive of the allegations exactly no
they never reached out to me and we when
this happened to you because I know
because I'm interview it was thirty
minutes later you told the woman you
were with and your lip was three times
it's normal size right and bleeding yes
the woman came back to the room and
found me when I didn't show up for the
seminar and of course I told her
immediately we'll look at the condition
I was in my clothes were torn my lip was
just huge and I was devastated and
afraid yeah goodness yes and did any
nobody and then Democrat the same people
that acting so indignant nothing no
absolutely nothing greg jarrett from a
legal standpoint the FBI's also said
that this is not within their
jurisdiction we played Joe Biden this
was a talking point for delay today
wasn't it that's right by law the FBI is
not allowed to investigate a non federal
crime they can only do background checks
and as Biden pointed out they simply
take witness statements they don't judge
guilt-ridden innocence or the
credibility of particular witnesses so
it was an utter canard over and over
today call for Cavanaugh to ask for an
FBI invest
well Juanita you were here today and
even during 2016 you felt compelled to
speak up about the double standard yeah
what do you say to those Democrats that
clearly this is about politics not about
what's right well this I clearly think
if senator Feinstein and Senator Durbin
had known that I was outside I think
they should have walked out and
apologized to me for what they did to me
in 1999 completely turning their backs
on me and Kathleen and Paula yes and
Jennifer who was called a liar exactly
yes I've known you a long time now god
bless you good to see you again yeah
thank you that we have talked about a
double standard oh I know I know here we
go again yeah